l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
sur le rapport de la commission mixte
paritaire de la proposition de loi
visant encadrer l'influence commerciale
et à lutter contre les dérives des
influenceurs sur les réseaux sociaux la
parole est à Monsieur Stéphane vogeta
rapporteur de la commission mixte
paritaire
[Applaudissements]
madame le présidente madame le ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques monsieur le
Cora porteur chers collègues nous voici
donc arrivé au terme d'un processus qui
a commencé pour moi logiquement sur les
réseaux sociaux c'était le 31 juillet
dernier qu'un utilisateur de Twitter
m'avait relayé des alertes relatant des
escroquerie et autres dérives de la part
d'influenceurs je lui avais alors
répondu que je suis vrai à ce sujet avec
beaucoup d'intérêt
ce sujet je l'ai effectivement suivi
mais je n'ai pas été le seul loin de là
outre mon corps rapporteur Arthur de la
porte nous sommes nombreux sur tous les
bancs de cette de cette émission à
l'avoir jugé digne d'intérêt
nous avons auditionné nous avons
travaillé et nous sommes arrivés à
plusieurs conclusions
l'influence commerciale manque trop
souvent de transparence
l'influence commerciale est trop souvent
utilisée pour contourner des règles qui
s'appliquent à la publicité sur ces
cadeaux traditionnels les acteurs de
l'influence commerciale ne sont pas
suffisamment responsabilités face à ces
dérives
il en résulte une vulnérabilité des
utilisateurs des réseaux sociaux
utilisateurs qui trop souvent deviennent
des victimes de publication commerciale
problématiques
victimes d'arnaque aux crypto monnaie au
paris sportifs aux pratiques
commerciales douteuses au dropshipping
ou au copy trading victime de
représentation irréalistes de visages et
de corps idéaux qui n'existent que sur
Photoshop ou à travers les filtres de
Tik Tok victime enfin d'un mode de
pensée où les rêves d'argent facile
remplacent le travail l'effort et le
mérite nous sommes nombreux dans cette
hémicycle à avoir jugé que ces victimes
méritaient notre attention avoir estimé
que les consommateurs et les
utilisateurs des réseaux méritaient la
protection de la loi notre conclusion
est rapidement devenue limpide
l'activité d'influence commerciale
devait être mieux définie et mieux
régulée
en votant cette loi ce soir vous le
ferez et vous enverrez donc un message
important à ces victimes oui les
parlementaires vous ont entendu et ils
ont agi pour vous
nous vous proposons donc de voter ce
soir définitivement un texte pour
l'instant fait l'objet de cinq votes
favorable en commission des affaires
économiques de l'Assemblée nationale à
l'unanimité en première lecture dans
cette hémicycle à l'unanimité en
commission des effets économiques du
Sénat à l'unanimité en séance au Sénat à
l'unanimité à nouveau et enfin en
commission mixte paritaire unanimité
j'espère que nous maintiendrons cette
belle tendance ce soir notamment car
nous vous proposons de valider un texte
que nos collègues sénateurs ont su
nourrir dans la continuité de l'esprit
du texte initié par vos deux corps
rapporteurs un texte qui n'obéit qu'à
une boussole protéger les consommateurs
une boussole avec ses quatre points
cardinaux clarifié encadré
responsabiliser et éduquer
l'encadrement c'est notamment rode
obligatoire l'établissement d'un contrat
écrit entre l'influenceur et son agence
ou son annonceur la responsabilisation
c'est reprendre et anticiper le
règlement européen sur les services
numériques le DSA et l'appliquer à
l'influence commerciale en imposant
ainsi aux plateformes des séries
d'obligations quand tu as des outils de
signalement et à la modération des
contenus l'éducation enfin s'est intégré
la notion de sensibilisation contre les
dangers d'ordre commercial au sein de la
formation risque numérique dispensés
dans nos établissements scolaires
ce texte a par ailleurs déjà fait preuve
de cette perte vertu pédagogique auprès
des acteurs de l'influence un texte qui
est aussi observé par de nombreux pays
qui nous regardent avec envie qui
regarde la France premier pays donc à
réguler l'activité d'influence d'une
manière transversale et équilibrée chers
pour tout cela je tiens à tous vous
remercier quel que soit votre couleur
politique j'en remercie également bien
sûr le gouvernement Bruno Le Maire
Olivia Grégoire Jean-Noël Barraud et
leurs équipes pour le travail réalisé en
confiance ce qui nous a permis d'avancer
aussi rapidement à ce propos madame le
ministre je m'excuse d'avoir sans doute
un peu bousculé le calendrier de Bercy
je m'excuse mais je ne peux pas vous
promettre pour autant de ne pas
commencer
bien sûr je remercie également les
lanceurs d'alerte
dont certains ont parfois eu besoin de
courage pour témoigner malgré les
pressions cependant chers collègues il
faut reconnaître que notre travail sur
ce texte c'est trop souvent déroulé
devant une toile de fond délétère la
diffusion de valeur détestable les
intimidations les menaces les
accusations croisées de harcèlement le
doxing toutes ces violences je les
condamne nous les condamnons et nous
appelons tous les acteurs de ce secteur
à la modération à la tempérance nous
avons touché du doigt des excès des
réseaux sociaux et la violence qui règne
trop souvent j'en ressors
personnellement encore plus convaincu de
la nécessité de continuer à agir alors
chers collègues chers Arthur je crois
qu'il est acté qu'il a certains sujets
sur lesquels nous ne nous mettrons
jamais d'accord mais je vous en conjure
il ne faut pas que cela nous empêche de
continuer à travailler ensemble dès
demain pour protéger les consommateurs
et notre jeunesse face aux dangers du
numérique et particulièrement des
réseaux l'examen du projet de loi
numérique est au coin de la rue et tous
ensemble nous avons la capacité de faire
vivre le débat et d'enrichir ce texte
pour continuer à construire des digues
efficaces contre l'accès des mineurs à
la pornographie contre les ARN aques en
ligne sous toutes leurs formes contre la
violence et le harcèlement sur internet
j'ai confiance en notre force notre
force collective dans la capacité de
notre Parlement à répondre aux attentes
des citoyens
avancer à force de à force de compromis
entre majorité et opposition comme sur
ce texte ne lâchons rien et vivre
l'initiative parlementaire
la parole est un monsieur Arthur de la
porte rapporteur de la commission mixte
paritaire
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le Cora porteur chez Stéphane
chers collègues notre Parlement est
décidément capable du pire comme du
meilleur
le pire nous l'avons vécu aujourd'hui en
commission des affaires sociales ou la
présidente a refusé et je tiens à le
rappeler ici d'examiner des amendements
et nier donc finalement un droit
constitutionnel le pire c'est donc ces
tensions qui ont pu nous opposer et qui
continueront force et de le constater
mais le meilleur c'est ce que nous
faisons ce soir et je pense que nous
avons préféré garder le meilleur pour la
fin
le meilleur c'est donc une loi une
proposition de loi qui a d'abord été
déposée examiné lors de la niche
socialiste mais qui a vu une main tendue
celle de Stéphane Végéta que je salue
ici et plus largement aussi celle de la
majorité parlementaire qui a vu qu'il y
avait un sujet dans notre proposition et
avec nos efforts convergence de Stéphane
Végéta mais aussi et il faut le
reconnaître et j'aurais l'honnêteté de
le dire ici la forme de bienveillance du
gouvernement à l'égard de l'initiative
parlementaire qui a eu lieu sur ce sujet
mais aussi et il faut le dire également
la force de travail de proposition de
nos collègues de l'ensemble des groupes
de l'arc républicains et je tiens en
particulier à saluer parce qu'elle est
ici devant moi c'est Amiot du groupe
insoumis mais aussi ceux qui avaient
déposé des propositions de loi n'a déjà
bon Mongolie François Piquemal ou encore
Aurélien taché pour l'aile gauche ou des
collègues de la droite républicaine en
particulier Virginie Vigner bref nous
avons montré que notre assemblée savait
travailler de concert de façon
concordante et même j'ose le dire
unanime
la loi que nous présentons ce soir ici
et finalement le fruit d'une quadruple
unanimité uneanimité à l'Assemblée
nationale uneanimité au Sénat sur un
texte différent
renforcer dans ses ambitions uneanimité
également en commission mixte paritaire
ou l'ensemble des parlementaires
présents ont voté les modifications
soumises par vos corps
uneanimité enfin et je crois qu'il nous
faut également le reconnaître de la
société civile organisée des acteurs du
monde de l'influence que ce soit les
représentants des agences les
influenceurs eux-mêmes qui ont soutenu
la loi les citoyens enfin et surtout les
consommateurs et les victimes ceux pour
qui nous avons travaillé et ce pour qui
nous nous sommes battus je pense donc ce
soir à toutes celles et ceux qui ont dit
ça suffit à toutes celles et ceux qui
ont dit mais que fait le Parlement et
qui se soit enfin se disent oui nous
avons été écoutés oui nous n'avons pas
été méprisés oui la représentation
nationale c'est saisi d'un sujet de
société d'un sujet majeur d'un sujet qui
avait des implications multiples en
termes de protection de la santé
publique en terme de protection des
consommateurs en termes des protections
des mineurs en termes de lutte contre
les dérives sexistes notamment
bref les influenceurs continueront
d'exister les influenceurs continueront
de travailler j'espère dans un cadre de
confiance grâce à la loi que nous
portons
les influx voleurs puisque c'est ainsi
qu'on les appelle existeront peut-être
toujours mais désormais ils seront que
la loi est là et qu'elle est là
notamment pour les punir que s'il
continue leur compte des réseaux sociaux
pourront être suspendus que si ils
continuent l'eau propre public existera
et c'est bien là le rôle de la loi c'est
de clarifier ce qui jusque là ne l'était
pas la loi de la jungle c'est fini et je
crois chers collègues que nous sommes
tous ici pour le dire cette bulle de
paix a des effets cet effet c'est
notamment de produire je le crois une
belle loi une belle loi et aussi une
belle image de notre Assemblée nationale
je disais ce soir nous faisons la preuve
du meilleur
j'espère que nous pourrons continuer sur
cette voie mon collègue Stéphane Végéta
après avoir résumé les principaux
apports de ce texte vous a également
tracé quelques pistes permettez-moi de
dire ce sur quoi je pense nous pouvons
continuer à travailler en cherchant le
consensus sur les sujets du numérique
comment mieux lutter contre le
cyber-harcèlement comment mieux protéger
en particulier les influenceuses qui
sont victimes de sexisme comment
responsabiliser aussi les marques et les
plateformes dans la lutte contre la
haine en ligne notamment qui déferne
comment défendre un modèle de
consommation qui soit plus vertueux plus
écologique et plus durable parce que
l'enjeu est là aussi
la protection de la santé publique c'est
une chose mais la protection de
l'environnement l'enjeu de demain devra
nous amener à réfléchir aussi plus
largement aux droits de la consommation
à l'air de la transition climatique
c'est pourquoi chers collègues les
enjeux restent ouverts nous resterons et
je pense l'ensemble des groupes de l'arc
républicains ouverts pour travailler sur
ces sujets comme sur d'autres en donnant
l'image du meilleur de l'Assemblée
nationale pour le meilleur pour notre
pays merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à Madame Olivia Grégoire
ministre délégué chargé des petites et
moyennes entreprises du commerce de
l'artisanat et du tourisme
[Applaudissements]
bonjour madame bonjour madame la
ministre
madame la Présidente messieurs les
rapporteurs de la porte et Vegeta
mesdames messieurs les députés
je serai brève
je n'aurais que quelques mots très
simples et aussi simple que court
bravo pour votre travail
il y a quelques mois des parlementaires
issus de différents groupes politiques
vous l'avez tous les deux rappelés mais
sur les rapporteurs faisaient part de
leur souhaits de travailler sur
l'encadrement de l'influence commerciale
il y a quelques mois Bruno Le Maire
lançait une vaste concertation un cadre
de travail pour réfléchir aux besoins de
cet écosystème d'influence commerciale
en essence il y a quelques mois vous
commenciez chers Stéphane Végéta mais
aussi chez Arthur de la porte à
travailler ensemble dans ce que vous
avez baptisé votre bulle de paix
force et de constater que cette bulle de
paix n'a pas éclaté mieux elle a pu
donner naissance à une proposition de
loi précise ambitieuse qui a su trouver
au Sénat le même consensus que dans
cette hémicycle comme le rapporteur
végétal a rappelé
sans entrer dans le détail de ce que
contient la version de cette proposition
de loi issue de la commission mixte
paritaire je me réjouis sincèrement des
débats qu'elle a suscité tantôt
Parlement que dans le débat public vous
l'avez dit Arthur de la porte ce sont
des débats qui traversent notre société
et il était important que c'est des
bases soient abordés et tranchées par la
représentation nationale c'est débats
ont permis à tous nos concitoyens de
prendre la mesure de ce phénomène au
premier rang desquels bien sûr les 150
000 Français qui exercent une activité
d'influence commerciale ils ont
dorénavant
un cadre clair un cadre qui leur permet
d'exercer leur travail en toute sécurité
juridique un cadre possiblement inédit
en Europe à cette fin je ferai une
proposition qui ne contrevient
aucunement à l'encadrement de
l'influence commerciale je vous propose
de faire en sorte que le guide de bonne
conduite présenté à la fin du mois de
mars dernier soit rapidement mise à jour
avec les apports précis de votre texte
pour que les influenceurs puissent à des
fautes se référer à Légifrance trouver
toutes les informations complètes au
sein d'un seul guide je ne serai pas
plus longue au nom du gouvernement
mon nom et en celui de Bruno Le Maire
qui suit le sujet je veux très
sincèrement vous renouvelez mes
félicitations pour l'excellent travail
mené tant sur le fond que sur la forme
et surtout sur le la visée de cette
proposition de loi protéger nos
compatriotes face à des abus au cœur de
cette influence commerciale et réguler
une influence commerciale qui est
majoritairement sérieusement menée
raison de plus pour l'encadrer je vous
remercie merci madame la ministre
la parole est à Madame violette spielbou
pour le groupe Renaissance
madame la présidente madame la ministre
messieurs les corsteurs mes chers
collègues ce soir j'ai d'abord une
pensée émue pour toutes les victimes des
arnaques et des excès sur les réseaux
sociaux celle que nous avons rencontré
lors des auditions et celles que nous ne
connaissons pas c'est avec fierté que je
participe donc ce soir à ce moment
marquant nous sommes réunis pour
protéger les consommateurs notamment les
plus jeunes et mieux réguler l'influence
commerciale à bien des égards chers
Stéphane Végéta cher Arthur de Laporte
vous avez réussi à faire ce que beaucoup
ont eu peur de tenter cette fameuse
bulle de paix dont vous parlez si bien
dans l'hémicycle souvent survoltés et
bien c'est une belle réussite inspirante
je l'espère pour bien d'autres thèmes la
fusion de vos deux textes puis le
travail transpartisan engagé par les
députés de la majorité et de
l'opposition ont permis de dégager un
consensus dont nous pouvons être fiers
collectivement après le passage en
commission puis dans l'hémicycle de nos
deux assemblées et enfin en commission
mixte commentaires député et sénateurs
ont réussi à se mettre d'accord pour une
avancée marquante nous sommes donc grâce
à cette nouvelle méthode et à nos
convictions partagées le premier pays du
monde à légiférer sur l'influence
commerciale avec des règles des
obligations et des protections par ce
vote nous allons montrer au monde entier
que la France est créatrice d'emploi et
de valeurs dans la filière de
l'influence tout en protégeant les
consommateurs et en sanctionnant les
mauvais comportements par cette
proposition de loi nous définissons
avant tout le statut de l'influence
commerciale mais aussi nous régulons
cette nouvelle activité nous luttons
contre tous les types d'arnaques
contrefaçon et autres pratiques
commerciales douteuses qui font bien
trop souvent la une des médias
ce texte issu de la commission mixte
paritaire retient notamment des avancées
marquantes notamment une définition de
l'activité d'influence commerciale
réelle avec l'obligation de signer des
contrats je salue le travail de
Eric Bothorel qui a beaucoup apporté sur
ce point l'interdiction de la promotion
de la chirurgie esthétique qui a tant
été dénoncée et de la médecine était
esthétique a été renforcée les contenus
comportant des partenariats rémunérés
devront maintenant afficher une
publicité une mention de publicité
obligatoire le cadre de la régulation
très stricte de la promotion des
produits de santé et maintenant inscrits
dans la loi tout cela ce sont des
avancées majeures mais nous avons aussi
l'obligation de d'afficher des mentions
sanitaires pour lesquelles notre
collègue Dominique Pottier a beaucoup
contribué l'interdiction de faire la
promotion de produits issus de la
nicotine s'ajoutant à celle du tabac et
de l'alcool et je salue car l'olive et
sa contribution et puis aussi la
protection des mineurs pour la promotion
des jeux d'argent et de hasard toutes
ces avancées sont majeures et
lorsqu'elles ne seront pas respectées et
bien il pourra avoir deux ans de prison
et 300 000 euros d'amende les sanctions
sont là nous pouvons donc être très fier
de toutes ces avancées qui mettent fin à
la fameuse loi de la jungle évoquée tout
à l'heure une vraie loi de la jungle que
nous avons tous constaté lorsque nous
avons été sollicités et nous sommes à
l'écoute des victimes nous continuerons
de l'être au quotidien tout en
continuant aussi de travailler avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de la filière de
l'influence avec qui nous avons su je
crois je crois trouver de vrais voix de
travail cette priorité a aussi été prise
à bras le corps par le gouvernement à
travers le guide de l'influenceur qui a
été présenté par Bruno Le Maire il y a
plusieurs semaines et je tiens aussi à
saluer le travail engagé par la ministre
Olivia Grégoire ses équipes pour rendre
l'ensemble de ces mesures opérantes nous
avons aussi beaucoup réfléchi et
travailler sur les dérives potentiels de
la publicité en général ce débat nous a
mobilisé avec le président kasbariian et
je suis sûr que nous poursuivrons les
travaux en ce sens mes chers collègues
nous avons une responsabilité et une
chance inouïe celle de structurer de
façon unique en Europe la nouvelle
filière de l'influence sur les réseaux
sociaux et les plateformes c'est
désormais dans la loi l'influence
commerciale est reconnue comme une
véritable filière économique le groupe
Renaissance est donc fier ce soir de
voter pour cette proposition de loi je
vous remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à Madame marine amelée pour
le groupe rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur les rapporteurs chers collègues
aujourd'hui c'est un feuilleton long de
trois mois qui s'achève enfin avec le
vote de cette proposition de loi un
premier texte avait été déposé en
février lors de la niche parlementaire
socialiste inabouti celui-ci avait été
retiré dans la foulée sous couvert d'une
collaboration rédactionnelle
transpartisane excluant cependant
officiellement le seul et le plus
important parti d'opposition de ce pays
de discussion cruciale et pourtant prise
à coeur par les députés du rassemblement
national
à nous seul nous avions en effet déposé
exactement la moitié des amendements
proposés en séance sur la première
version de ce texte c'est au total une
cinquantaine d'amendements toute version
confondues qui ont été déposées pour
nourrir cette proposition de loi de
mesures pertinentes
en sachant cela l'on comprend mal les
propos de Monsieur Delaporte qui encore
hier divaguaient sur BFM TV pour sur la
prétendue incurie du rassemblement
national vis-à-vis de la régulation du
marché de l'influence alors que nous
n'avons eu de cesse de dénoncer les
contreérités proférées à tout va à ce
sujet d'ailleurs un mensonge doit être
levé avec plus d'énergie que les autres
non le marché de l'influence n'a jamais
été le no man's land qu'on a bien voulu
nous décrire les influenceurs ne sont
rien d'autre que des publicitaires et
ils sont à ce titre soumis au même loi
que n'importe quelle agence de publicité
la levée de boucliers d'une myriade
d'influenceurs de renom autour d'une
déclaration commune contre ce texte en
mars dernier témoignent avant tout de
l’incompréhension de milliers de
créateurs qui respectent la loi désignée
du jour au lendemain comme qui
respectent la loi désignée pardon du
jour au lendemain comme des parias et
des escrocs
ces raccourcis dont je dangereux pardon
se fonder pour la plupart sur une
enquête réalisée par la direction
générale de la concurrence de la
consommation et de la répression des
fraudes en quête qui révélait que 6
influenceurs sur 10 en freinent la loi
ces chiffres doivent cependant être
nuancés par ceux de l'Observatoire de
l'influence responsable qui dévoile
qu'en 2022 le taux de manquement aux
règles en vigueur était davantage le
fait des influenceurs possédant une
faible audience avec un taux de
manquement à 35% des contenus analysés
tandis que les influenceurs à forte
audience tentent à se professionnaliser
à rebours de la stigmatisation générale
des influenceurs il faut mettre en
exergue que le haut niveau d'infraction
constaté par la DGCCRF et d'abord le
symptôme de la nouveauté de cette
activité et des conditions de sa
professionnalisation
l'absurdité du métier d'influenceur
c'est qu'il passe nécessairement par une
phase d'amateurisme avec des
influenceurs pour la plupart
ignorant de la loi à leur début
légiférer le marché d'influence implique
donc de distinguer trois types
d'influenceurs ceux qui n'enfraînent pas
la loi car il la connaissent ce qu'il en
fera une délibérément et ceux qui
l'entraînent inconsciemment pour les
premiers cette proposition de loi elle
mérite d'apporter des garanties
contractuelles définies mais qui
s'accompagne toutefois de contraintes
supplémentaires en matière de publicité
pour les seconds ceux qui enfreignent
délibérément la loi il est évident que
la présente aux propositions devraient
n'avoir que peu de conséquences
puisqu'il suffit en fait de se rendre à
Dubaï pour échapper aux droits français
c'est là que le bât blesse certes le
texte propose d'imposer aux influenceurs
étrangers établis à l'étranger de se
faire représenter légalement afin de les
sanctionner s'ils apprennent la loi mais
dès lors qu'il refuserait de se faire
représenter comme en comptez-vous les
sanctionner enfin concernant les
influenceurs qui enfreignent la loi par
ignorance l'on ne peut que regretter que
notre proposition n'est pas été retenue
pour rappel elle visait à conditionner
le droit de contractualisation par
exemple avec un annonceur à l'obtention
du certificat de l'influence responsable
de la RPP qui existe déjà et qui
dispense pourtant les bases juridiques
en matière de publicité
officiellement écarté des discussions
nous nous félicitons toutefois de notre
que notre pugnacité et permis de faire
adopter officieusement les mesures de
protection et de sensibilisation des
mineurs que nous réclamions depuis le
début tels que l'article 5 d'une part
qui est d'ailleurs le seul article
inchangé depuis le départ et qui reprend
tel quel un amendement du rassemblement
national déposé lors de l'examen en
commission de la première proposition de
loi visant à mettre en place des séances
de prévention et de sensibilisation au
risque d'escroqueries en ligne dans les
établissements scolaires
et d'autre part tels que l'intégration
d'un dispositif prévu au paragraphe 3 de
l'article 2B visant à prévenir
totalement l'exposition des enfants aux
publicités pour les jeux d'argent quand
le texte initial se contentait d'un
simple avertissement
pour les raisons que je viens d'évoquer
nous n'irons pas jusqu'à claméo et fort
que ce texte révolutionnera le monde de
l'influence mais il aura néanmoins le
mérite de participer à l'amélioration du
climat général voilà pourquoi nous le
voterons merci madame la députée la
parole est à Monsieur François Piquemal
pour le groupe la France insoumise
nupesse
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs Aurore a perdu
350 euros sur un site de trading
Sébastien attend toujours ses écouteurs
jamais reçus plus grave Leila mutilé par
des injections sauvages d'acide
hyaluronique Véronique qui a perdu les
économies de son ménage 10000 euros dans
des placements financiers obscurs oui il
était temps de mettre fin à la loi de la
jungle sur les réseaux sociaux il était
temps que les influx voleurs sachent que
leurs arnaques ne resteront plus
impunies ces influx voleurs avatar d'un
capitalisme sauvage si tenté qu'il est
qu'il ait été un jour civilisé tant il
n'est jamais lunatique pour imposer sa
brutalité ces afflux voleurs qui
proposent du contenu valorisant leur
quotidien de fraudeur fiscaux à Dubaï ou
dans d'autres enfers ecocides des
arnaqueurs en jet ski écl sans leurs
auditoires d'arnaque au compte formation
à la chirurgie esthétique au complément
alimentaire au dropshipping aux produits
en toc sur insta ou sur TikTok en deux
trois clics ou en deux trois like juste
ici il passait au calme entre les
mailles du filet et pour cause une seule
condamnation à ce jour assez minime il
convient donc de remercier les
collectifs comme avis vos stars en
réalité et le rappeur Booba qui ont
chacun jouait un rôle de lanceur à
d’alerte sur les pratiques de ces gens
mettre fin à ces pratiques mieux définir
le statut d'influenceur renforcer des
moyens de la direction générale de la
concurrence de la consommation et de la
répression des fraudes ont été l'objet
de plusieurs travaux parlementaires je
tiens ici à saluer pour cela mes
collègues Aurélien tachés Ségolène Amiot
et Nadège à beaumont-goli ainsi que tous
les deux messieurs de la porte et Vegeta
avec ces dernières avec ces dernières
collègues nous nous félicitons des
avancées de cette loi sur la définition
des influenceurs le meilleur contrôle
des produits financiers et crypto
monnaie le maintien de l'interdiction de
la promotion de la chirurgie et de la
médecine esthétique l'interdiction de se
mettre en scène avec des animaux dont la
détention est interdite en France
l'obligation de souscrire pour les
influenceurs opérant depuis l'étranger à
une assurance civile dans l'Union
européenne pour indemniser d'éventuelles
victimes toutefois nous tenons à faire
quelques avertissements nuances et
mettre quelques regrets d'abord nous
avertissons sur l'importance qu'il y a à
donner davantage de moyens à la DGCCRF
pour accompagner cette loi ensuite nous
mettons en garde sur la question des
signes à l'heure de confiance on ne sait
pas encore
qui sera en mesure de signaler c'est
également un danger car donner le
pouvoir de retirer du contenu à des qui
ne seront probablement pas neutres peut
entraîner des dérives graves la priorité
donc de renforcer le service judiciaire
et de police contre les dérives plutôt
que de déléguer ce pouvoir nous nous
regrettons aussi que rien ne soit
mentionné sur les obligations
d'indication pour les contenus de
promotion et les contenus modifiés or
selon un rapport de la DGCCRF publié le
23 janvier dernier sur la soixantaine
d'influenceurs et d'agences qu'elle a
ciblé depuis 2021 6 sur 10 ne respectez
pas la réglementation sur la publicité
et les droits des consommateurs enfin
nous aurions aimé une vraie politique
publique de communication à l'égard des
utilisateurs des réseaux sociaux
particulièrement les jeunes avec des
campagnes de prévention en lien avec les
associations
malgré c'est lacunes la loi proposée
aujourd'hui permet de remettre de la
justice
là où il n'y a encore que quelques
années c'était des moqueries car oui ce
sujet disons-le et restez trop longtemps
en dehors des discours politiques des
considérés ou pas pris au sérieux
souvent comme les victimes qui en
étaient l'objet alors comme dirait un
célèbre pas et pirate je vous le dis
pour nous aujourd'hui c'est validé
merci monsieur le député
la parole est à madame Béatrice Descamps
pour le groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire
madame la présidente madame la ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues
avec les réseaux sociaux est apparu à
nouveau monde fait de like de clics et
d'abonnés les influenceurs ils sont rois
et ne souffrait jusqu'à là d'aucune
contestation mais les temps ont changé
nous découvrons aujourd'hui une phase
plus sombre très sombre de cet univers
les paillettes ont laissé place aux
formations douteuses aux produits
controversés aux arnaques et le
législateur
ne pouvait faire sans s'emparer de ce
sujet merci monsieur le rapporteur de
l'avoir fait à ce titre je veux saluer
le travail transpartisan mené par notre
assemblée des députés de tous les
horizons réussis à avancer
collectivement c'est suffisamment rare
pour être relevé
un consensus c'est donc dégagé sur la
nécessité de créer un nouveau cadre
juridique pour que l'ensemble des
influenceurs neptisent pas des méfaits
de quelques-uns pour qu'influenceurs
cesse de rimer avec voleur la première
étape a été d'apporter une définition à
ce nouveau métier cette
issue de compromis entre Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat nous semble
aujourd'hui satisfaisante elle englobe
désormais l'ensemble des personnes qui
mobilisent leur notoriété sur les
réseaux sociaux pour en tirer des
bénéfices que ces bénéfices soient en
nature ou financiers d'ailleurs
second sujet encadrez la promotion des
produits en ligne il sera désormais
interdit entre autres de faire
l'apologie de la chirurgie esthétique du
tabac de l'alcool de certains produits
et services financiers de jeux de hasard
ou encore de paris sportifs en bref nos
deux chambres ont établi une liste très
complète d'activités à ne plus
promouvoir ce sont ces produits qui
permettent aujourd'hui à des
influenceurs peu scrupuleux de faire
fortune en tirant profit de la naïveté
de la communauté
concrètement le couple n'adé Marc data
ne pourront plus inciter leur follower à
investir dans les crypto-monnaies et
Dylan devra cesser la promotion de
gélules qui guérissent les cellules
cancéreuses auprès de ces 1 million cinq
d'abonnés sur Instagram
une problématique reste sur la table la
question de la promotion de la malbouffe
nous aurions souhaité que toute
publicité soit interdite sur les réseaux
sociaux vous le savez il est de plus en
plus souvent fait à l'âge de ces
produits trop gras trop salé ou trop
sucré sur ces médias pourtant leurs
effets sur la santé des adolescents sont
désastreux et les plus jeunes sont
particulièrement influençables
vous avez préféré vous cantonnez un
simple encadrement les réseaux sociaux
se verront donc appliquer les mêmes
normes que les publicités
traditionnelles mais je garde espoir de
nous retrouver bientôt pour aller plus
loin sur la question par ailleurs les
photos vidéos de visage de silhouette
modifié devront porter la mention image
retouchée ou image virtuelle c'est
important pour éviter la promotion vidéo
de beauté inaccessible pour les
internautes concernant le cadre plus
global de très nombreuses publications
touchant un public français sont émises
par des influenceurs Français résidant
en dehors de l'Union Européenne
notamment aux Émirats arabes unis aux
États-Unis alors même que leur notoriété
s'est construite auprès de ce public il
a en résulte des difficultés de
régulation ainsi nous sommes favorables
à ce que ces influenceurs installés à
l'étranger soient soumis aux droits
français des contrats d'influence
commerciale nous considérons aussi qu'il
faut imposer à ces derniers de désigner
un représentant légal établi sur le
territoire de l'Union Européenne afin de
faciliter la coopération sur les
autorités administratives et judiciaires
nationales
ce texte prévoit enfin un renforcement
des pouvoirs de police administrative de
la DGCCRF et une augmentation du montant
des amendes là aussi les évolutions sont
positives reste qu'elles ne seront
opérationnelles qu'à condition de donner
des moyens humains technologiques et
financier aux organes de contrôle j'en
appelle un la responsabilité de
gouvernement les 15 agents destinés à
former une brigade de l'influence
commerciale annoncée par Monsieur le
Ministre de l'économie seront-ils
suffisants
hormis ces quelques petits bémols mon
groupe considère que cette proposition
de loi permettra de clarifier bien sûr
les droits et les devoirs des 150 000
influenceurs
qui peuvent ce qui peuplent la toile et
de mieux protéger nos concitoyens
particulièrement les plus jeunes nous y
sommes donc favorables merci madame la
députée
la parole est à Madame Louise Morel pour
le groupe démocrate modem et indépendant
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de commission
messieurs les corrateurs mes chers
collègues cette lecture des conclusions
de la commission mixte paritaire et
remarquable à plusieurs titres tout
d'abord parce que son adoption permettra
d'inscrire pour la toute première fois
dans la loi la définition de l'activité
d'influenceurs et ainsi d'accorder aux
influenceurs une reconnaissance
juridique avec des règles qui leur
incombent remarquable ensuite parce que
ce texte est la preuve que sur bien des
sujets un travail transpartisan est
possible cette bulle de paix comme ont
aimé la nommer nos deux corps à porteurs
aura permis de faire de la protection du
consommateur et de l'ordre public
économique notre priorité du début à la
fin de cette initiative parlementaire et
c'est finalement cela faire de la
politique créer des majorités au service
de l'intérêt général voici une donnée
éloquente pour démontrer la nécessité de
cette régulation
le marché mondial de l'influence était
estimée à 16,4 milliards de dollars en
2022 ce poids économique a suscité un
intérêt majeur et aller de pair avec
l'augmentation du nombre d'arnaques en
tout genre escroquerie pratique
commerciale trompeuses fraude massive
alors ou en enfant passe en moyenne
entre 9 et 13 heures par semaine devant
un ordinateur il était
urgent de légiférer sur l'influence
commerciale c'est désormais chose faite
avec cette loi la France est l'un des
premiers pays au monde sinon le seul à
se doter d'un arsenal juridique visant à
encadrer l'influence commerciale sur les
réseaux sociaux et à lutter contre les
arnaques et les dérives quelques mots
sur cette proposition de loi telle
qu'elle résulte de la commission mixte
paritaire elle pose d'abord une
définition claire du statut des
influenceurs et des agents
d'influenceurs elle a sorti cette
activité dans le régime d'O et
d'interdictions propres à cette pratique
commerciale en ligne qui est accompagné
deux sanctions et de contrôle spécifique
deuxièmement ce texte interdit certaines
publicités qui n'ont pas leur place sur
les réseaux sociaux les influenceurs ne
pourront plus faire la promotion de la
chirurgie esthétique de certains
produits et services financiers ou
encore de pronostics sportifs
troisièmement ce texte garantit une
meilleure information des utilisateurs
des réseaux sociaux par exemple les
contenus promotionnels devront avoir une
mention publicité ou collaboration
commerciale lisible sur leur contenu la
connaissance étant la clé du pouvoir
nous rendons ainsi aux consommateurs le
pouvoir d'acheter en toute connaissance
de cause un produit promu par son
influenceur préféré gage donc d'une plus
grande transparence enfin ce texte
accorde une place centrale à la
protection des utilisateurs les plus
vulnérables pour protéger les plus
jeunes de nos concitoyens trop souvent
soumis à l'illusion d'une perfection
inatteignable et illusoire des visages
et décors les photos et vidéos de visage
ou de silhouettes modifiées devront
obligatoirement porter la mention images
retouchées ou images virtuelle des
mesures spécifiques via également
protégées les enfants influenceurs qui
seront soumis au même règle que celles
encadrant les enfants youtubeurs
conformément au digital services actes
il faut également souligner que les
obligations des plateformes en ligne
sont elles aussi renforcées je
terminerai en soulignant l'engagement
sincère du groupe démocrate sur ce texte
qui s'est largement investi dans les
débats plusieurs mesures émanant des
députés de notre groupe ont été adoptés
l'inscription de la responsabilité
solidaire entre l'influenceur et son
agent en cas de fraude l'encadrement
plus stricte de la pratique du
dropshipping c'est-à-dire une vente sur
Internet dans laquelle le vendeur
en l'occurrence l'influenceur ne se
charge que de la commercialisation et de
la vente du produit mais pas de sa
livraison également l'interdiction de la
promotion des produits
issus de la contrefaçon ou encore le
respect du Code de la propriété
intellectuelle dans les contrats qui
lient les influenceurs en cela je tiens
à saluer le travail des députés
Christophe Blanchet et Laurent esquenet
gauces avec lesquels j'ai eu le plaisir
de travailler sur ces questions pour
conclure le texte a le mérite d'être
suffisamment général pour encadrer un
maximum de situations il permet de poser
en jalon à la sécurisation de notre
modèle social sur internet en protégeant
les utilisateurs des réseaux sociaux
d'une part tout en offrant un cadre
juridique stable pour les professionnels
de l'influence d'autre part ce n'est
donc pas un combat contre les
influenceurs c'est un combat pour faire
de l'influence une véritable filière
économique c'est pourquoi le groupe
démocrate votera en faveur de l'adoption
de ce texte je vous remercie merci
madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Dominique Gauthier pour le
groupe socialiste et apparentés
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
tout d'abord dire merci Arthur de
Laporte et Stéphane vogeta merci pour la
clarté merci pour ce beau récit
aujourd'hui on en avait partiellement
besoin aujourd'hui d'avoir une belle
image de notre assemblée merci de nous
l'offrir moi j'aime cette idée que dans
l'Assemblée nationale dans le débat
démocratique il y a il y a deux choses
qui sont belles c'est quand on s'oppose
dans la clarté parce que c'est édifiant
pour la démocratie que démocratie que de
s'opposer dans la clarté pas dans le
Marais dans le une sorte de en même
temps un flou idéologique la clarté du
débat et des clivages c'est édifiant
mais il y a aussi c'est tout aussi
édifiant que dans cette carte là nous
soyons capables de nous rassembler parce
qu'on appelle une intelligence
collective une capacité de nous
rassembler face notamment à des défis
nouveaux ce que nous ça apporte la
modernité c'est ce que vous avez fait
avec brio aujourd'hui et depuis quelques
mois en vous rencontrant vous entend en
croisant vos regards et en intégrant des
remarques et des propositions venues
quasiment de tout l'arc républicain
bravo pour cette démonstration cette loi
somme toute se résume à une forme
d'itération du droit à une extension au
domaine de l'influence des règles qui
prévalent aujourd'hui dans l'ensemble de
la publicité le combat que j'ai porté au
nom des socialiste certains ont été
perdus notamment autour de la réduction
aux mineurs au nom de leur protection
d'autres ont été retenus parfois dans
les affres et des débats vifs au sein de
la commission mix paritaire je vous
remercie pour la fidélité à l'engagement
de la prise en compte de la question de
la malbouffe sur lequel j'ai entendu
plusieurs députés se s'entendre je crois
que c'est un rendez-vous pour demain sur
la balle bouffe nous avons pas été assez
loin mais nous avons au moins clairement
dans la loi
identifier cette question parce que
c'est une question de justice sociale
absolument majeure deux chiffres
simplement l'obésité c'est deux fois
plus qu'il y a 20 ans
dans les milieux populaires c'est deux
fois plus que dans les milieux aisés
deux fois plus en 20 ans deux fois plus
dans les milieux populaires et nous
consacrons 800 millions de publicités
c'est un chiffre donné par Loïc
Prudhomme dans un rapport que l'avait
fait en commission de la fabrication
économique 800 millions de publicités à
vendre du gras sucré et industrialisé à
des enfants souvent ceux qui n'ont pas
le contrepoids et le contre-pouvoir
culturel pour manger autrement manger
sain etc c'est très clairement une
atteinte à la question de l'égalité
sociale c'est une atteinte à la question
de la santé publique c'est une
discrimination sociale c'est une c'est
une injustice majeure désormais un
minima oui nous avons des rendez-vous
pour demain le combat n'est pas terminé
mais un minimum l'influence prendra en
compte cette question de la malbouffe au
même titre que les autres dérivent que
vous aviez signalé initialement et nous
nous ont félicitons mais devons-nous
nous en arrêter là non parce que je le
pense profondément c'est l'ensemble de
la pub qui aujourd'hui n'est pas assez
l'ensemble de la pub savez-vous chers
collègues que bis et Big corpo une ONG
qui l'a révélé c'est 31 milliards 31
milliards que nous consacrons tous les
ans et que nous payons français à
travers nos produits nos consommations
notre mode de vie 31 milliards qui
façonnent notre imaginaires 31 milliards
de servitudes marchandes quand nous
avons en face en termes de puissance
publique sur l'ensemble totalisant
l'ensemble de ce qui se fait en termes
de prévention santé publique c'est 3
milliards 7 soit 11% de la publicité
aujourd'hui
si nous rajoutons simplement les
chiffres de l'ADEME en termes
d'engagement de la transition écologique
nous sommes à peine à 15%. donc nous
sommes une société qui consens la
puissance privée
85% de la fabrication de son imaginaire
c'est un système qui n'est pas durable
c'est une forme de servitude dont nous
devons nous libérer cette question du
langage qui a été trop longtemps un
angle mort de la République et qui a
laissé se développer une forme
d'idolâtrie du marché nous devons la
combattre et restituer à l'Agora public
à la RSE publica la capacité investir un
langage c'est le combat de la RSE c'est
le combat de la de la directive
européenne en cours de discussion et qui
est très combattu par les libéraux et
les conservateurs autour du reporting
extra-financier qui donnerait à l'Europe
la capacité à émettre à être venir une
puissance normative dans le monde et
pour notre pays ce combat contre
l'imaginaire marchande nous devons
continuer à le poursuivre il est celui
d'éducation civique de l'éducation
populaire il est sud de la puissance
publique il est tout simplement celui de
la République chers collègues et je suis
heureux que par cette in itiative nous
ayons mis un peu de régulation dans ce
monde trop souvent trop brute et que
nous puissions par ce combat si mineur
soit-il contribué à ce grand récit qui
était celui d'Abraham Lincoln dans un
discours célèbre de septembre
1862 où il rappelait que en libérant
l'esclave nous redonnons sa liberté à
l'homme libre merci
monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Luc lamiro pour
le groupe horizon et apparenté
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues nous
examinons aujourd'hui la proposition de
loi issue de la commission mixte
paritaire visant à lutter contre les
arnaques et les dérives des influenceurs
sur les réseaux sociaux présentés par
nos collègues Stéphane vogeta et Arthur
de Laporte
qui prévoit la création d'un statut
d'influenceur et une régulation
renforcée de cette activité
professionnelle c'est une fierté pour
notre assemblée que d'examiner
aujourd'hui ce texte c'est la première
fois que les parlementaires que nous
sommes légifère sur le sujet de
l'influence commerciale et c'est la
première fois qu'un pays de l'Union
européenne s'apprête à adopter une loi
dédiée à ce sujet faisant de la France
un pays à l'avant-garde de la régulation
de l'économie numérique
certaines personnalités publiques
bénéficiant d'une large audience
numérique utilise les réseaux sociaux à
des fins commerciales au travers de
partenariats conclu avec des marques
qu'elle valorise pour leur diffusion de
contenu
nous avons tous conscience des dérives
que peuvent causer les réseaux sociaux
et leur impact sur nos jeunes
générations des influenceurs qui
trompent leur communauté avec des faux
traitements médicaux des produits
existants sur le marché revendus plus
cher des promotions d'achat risqué les
exemples sont nombreux en ce sens le
texte prévoit d'interdire aux
influenceurs la création de certaines
promotions
en particulier dès lors que des risques
existent pour la santé ou lorsqu'il
s'agit de placement ou d'investissement
risqué notamment sur le 2 dans le
domaine des crypto monnaies
face aux nombreux cas de dissimulation
du caractère commercial des publicités
faites par certains influenceurs la loi
prévoit également une obligation
d'information du public y compris sur
les pratiques de vente afin d'éviter les
cas de surfacturation du consommateur
pour un produit en tout point
identique à ce que l'on trouve beaucoup
moins cher sur le marché
la relation contractuelle entre
influenceurs agent a d’influenceurs et
annonceur a par exemple été renforcé et
sécurisé par l'obligation d'établir un
contrat écrit entre les parties
l'activité d'influence commerciale a été
davantage encadrée que ce soit sur les
promotions ou sur la nécessité nécessite
nécessaire transparence vis-à-vis du
public du caractère publicitaire ou
commercial des contenus
nous avons également renforcé les
pouvoirs de la DGCCRF en matière de
régulation des contenus par la création
d'une astreinte dans le cadre du
dispositif d'injonction administrative
avec le renforcement de la procédure de
blocage judiciaire de l'Autorité des
Marchés nous permettront de renforcer
nos outils pour protéger les
consommateurs
plusieurs amendements adoptés permettent
d'ailleurs une meilleure coordination du
texte avec les évolutions prévues au
niveau européen dans le cadre du digital
service actes notamment en matière de
signalement des contenus illicites
enfin
un rapport d'évaluation de la loi à deux
ans permettra de faire un premier point
d'étape et d'établir si les moyens
humains et financiers de la régulation
mobilisée sur son son proportionné à la
part grandissante des dérives et des
abus contexte constatés sur le marché de
la Fluence en ligne
je tiens à saluer le travail
transpartisant et constructif réalisé
par notre assemblée qui a permis
d'aboutir sur un texte pour la
proposition donc pour la protection de
nos concitoyens notamment les plus
jeunes d'entre eux
le groupe Horizon est apparenté partage
la volonté de mieux encadrer ce domaine
d'activité et de mieux y faire appliquer
les règles commerciales
ce sentiment est largement partagé en
témoigne l'adoption de la présente
proposition de la loi à l'unanimité en
séance publique tant à l'Assemblée
nationale qu'au Sénat
partageons donc cette volonté de mieux
réguler le marché de l'influence en
ligne dans l'intérêt tant des
professionnels que des utilisateurs et
consommateurs des plateformes le groupe
horizon et apparenté votre a en faveur
de la présente proposition de loi je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Hubert Julien
Laferrière pour le groupe écologiste
nups
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
messieurs les rapporteurs nous y sommes
après des mois d'alerte d'échanges
fructueux parfois de tergiversation
autour des dérives de nombreuses
influenceurs nous allons voter ce soir
une loi transpartisane pour encadrer
cette activité nocive
Dylan Terry qui vendent des produits
tuant les cellules
cancérigeuses en français dans le texte
Julien tanti 6 millions d'abonnés sur
Instagram qui vendent la poudre à
charbon sans ces blanchir les dents mais
reconnu comme dangereuse pour la santé
la liste de ces arnaques de ce que nous
appelons aujourd'hui les influenceurs
les influx voleurs elle est longue et
nous ne connaissons certainement qu'une
infime partie de leur ampleur face à ces
arnaques qui fleurissent sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis des années nombre de
députés de cette Assemblée on fait leur
travail leur travail de parlementaire et
ils ont alerté le gouvernement sur les
nombreuses dérives
je voudrais excuser mon collègue
Aurélien Tachet qui
me racontait comment pendant des mois
l'excuser parce qu'il est absent en
circonscription il était interpellé par
des jeunes dans sa circonscription sur
l'ampleur des arnaques liés aux
influenceurs ça a été dit les
principales victimes sont souvent des
jeunes les principales victimes sont
souvent des jeunes des quartiers
populaires je voudrais vraiment saluer
ce travail d'expertise qui a effectué
mon collègue aurait détaché par sa
proposition de voix mais aussi François
pigman n'a déjà bon Mongolie parce que
parce que par vos propositions de loi et
bien vous avez contribué à poser un
premier cadre légal à l'activité
influenceurs et à définir un nouveau
régime de responsabilité applicable à
ces derniers
en complément de cette loi transpartis
jeune il faudra certainement un problème
qui n'est pas d'ailleurs du domaine
législatif parce qu'il faut encadrer
mais il faut évidemment pouvoir
sanctionner or on le sait la DGCCRF mais
aujourd'hui pas doté des moyens
financiers et techniques pour agir de
nombreuses
pardon de nombreuses sanctions
escroquerie parlant reste impuni alors
que des sanctions pourraient déjà être
prises si une véritable volonté existait
tout semble permis sur un marché
aujourd'hui 100 fois nous ni loi il
faudra donc que les moyens de la DGCCRF
soit augmentée
les rapporteurs ont effectivement
rappelé le travail de nombreux collègues
que j'ai cités et d'autres qui ont
effectivement contribués à au travail
transpartisan à la proposition de loi
transpartisanes qui nous est aujourd'hui
présenté et qui ont conduit le ministre
Bruno Le Maire a annoncé le lancement
d'une consultation citoyenne mais aussi
des mesures législatives des mesures
réglementaires et finalement un plan
pour en finir avec la jungle des
influenceurs c'est là que notre
assemblée montre son utilité c'est là
que notre assemblée montre son beau
visage mais celui-là rapporteur votre
proposition de loi c'est effectivement
l'aboutissement de ce travail partisan
transpartisan pardon lapsus et je ne
doute pas effectivement que nous
voterons votre position de loi à
l'unanimité en tout cas notre assemblée
elle montre ce soir qu'elle est capable
de vrais compromis au service de nos
concitoyens je voudrais saluer également
le travail qui a été mené en CMP et
notamment l'amendement retenu de ma
collègue Lisa belluco qui a interdit aux
influenceurs de mettre en scène des
animaux un nouveau saluons ce travail
collectif ce travail transpartisan et le
groupe écologiste bien sûr votre a pour
cette proposition de voix je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Soumia bouroua
pour le groupe gauche-démocrate et
républicaine Lupin
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues notre cadre légal tel qu'il
est tel qu'il était défini jusqu'à
présent permettait aux influenceurs et
influenceuses de jouir d'une certaine
liberté dans leur activité
promotionnelle car la législation en
vigueur n'était que peu adaptée à ces
nouvelles pratiques commerciales
pourtant ces activités n'échappent pas
aux dérives arnaque au placement
financier arnaque au compte personnel de
formation promotion des médicaments et
d'actes de chirurgie esthétique ou
encore publicité pour des jeux d'argent
et de hasard en sont quelques exemples
très suivis
par un public majoritairement jeune et
donc plus influençable protéger ses
consommateurs et consommatrices et
devenu indispensable face à des
influenceurs qui ne respectent pas
certains cadres légaux et des roches aux
règles des plateformes qui les hébergent
grâce à cette proposition de loi la
France devient aujourd'hui l'un des
premiers pays à légiférer sur cette
activité nouvelle et ainsi définir
l'encadrement de ces pratiques aussi je
tiens à remercier les rapporteurs de ce
texte et saluer leur travail avec le
groupe de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine nous partageons l'essentiel
des ambitions de ce texte et notamment
la définition de l'activité
d'influenceurs tel qu'elle a été adoptée
la seule remarque que nous souhaitons
faire concerne le lien très spécifique
et unit l'influenceur ou l'influenceuse
à ce qu'on appelle ça communauté
ce lien d'affluence n'existerait pas
dans une sens une relation de confiance
particulière qui peut se rapporter à une
forme d'emprise psychologique pourquoi
tout simplement parce que l'activité
d'influenceurs ne se limite pas avant de
produits ou des services à sa communauté
pour lequel les entreprises les
rémunèrent ensuite l'activité
commerciale se mêlent souvent aux mises
en scène de la vie quotidienne où les
internautes se projettent parfois
fantasme c'est la persistance de ce de
ce faux lien de proximité voire
d'intimité que l'influenceur entretient
avec son public qui lui permet de
construire cette influence
par ailleurs nous partageons également
l'ambition de cette proposition de loi à
travers la création d'un statut d'agent
d'influenceurs car les responsabilités
promotionnelles sont en réalité
partagées de plus dans le cas des
influenceurs installés hors de l'Union
Européenne et dont les contenus visent
un public français nous soutenons la
volonté des rapporteurs qu'ils soient
représentés par une personne morale ou
physique en France nous sommes également
satisfaits du renforcement de
l'interdiction de la promotion de la
chirurgie de la médecine esthétique par
les influenceurs
l'interdiction de la publicité des
produits contenant de la nicotine est
également une très bonne nouvelle en
revanche nous aurions souhaité que cette
interdiction soit également étendue aux
boissons alcoolisées et non seulement à
travers la loi Eva nous regrettons
également que la publicité concernant
les jeux de hasard et les paris sportifs
n'est pas fait l'objet d'une mesure
similaire évidemment le rappel de
l'interdiction de ces pratiques au
mineur est important mais cette
addiction étant de plus en plus répandue
nous aurions préférés qu'elle ne fasse
pas l'objet de publicité en confiance à
banalise sa banalisation
par ailleurs nous émettons quelques
réserves sur les sur le rôle des signes
à l'heure de confiance chargés de faire
remonter les contenus illicites de la
direction générale de la concurrence de
la consommation et de la répression des
fraudes faire appel à des associations
de consommateurs ou à des activités
privées ne nous apparaît pas judicieux
alors que ces missions devraient être
assumées par l'État nous regrettons
enfin le nombre d'agents au sein de la
brigade spécialisée de la
DGCRF pour précéder au contrôle et aux
enquêtes ne soient toujours pas
suffisant alors que celle-ci relève que
les pratiques de 60% des influenceurs
contrôlent dans le cadre de ces enquêtes
ne sont pas conformes à la
réglementation vous l'aurez compris nous
aurions souhaité que ce texte aille
encore un peu plus loin et pose les
désinterdits clairs en matière de
publicité concernant les produits de
santé de jeux d'argent et de hasard ou
de produits financiers et de crypto
monnaie qui seront certes mieux régulées
mais pour toujours faire l'objet de
promotion
pour autant nous considérons qu'il
s'agit d'une première pierre
indispensable pour lutter contre les
dérives des influenceurs et pour la
protection des droits des consommateurs
et je vous remercie encore une fois
Monsieur les rapporteurs pour ce travail
c'est pourquoi le groupe GDR votera ce
texte je vous remercie merci madame la
députée
mes chers collègues il y a un bruit
ambiant
dans l'hémicide qui commence à devenir
fort désagréable tout du moins pour
l'orateur donc je vous demanderai je
vous demanderai de sortir si vous avez
des conversations très importantes
j'imagine que les conversations sont
très importantes donc je vous invite à
sortir pour continuer vos conversations
et si c'est une conversation ne sont pas
si importantes que ça je vous invite à
écouter l'orateur la parole est amuse à
abandonner la parole aux dernières
orateur je vous informe que sur le vote
de la proposition de loi telle qu'elle
est issue de la CMP je suis saisie par
le groupe Renaissance le groupe la
France insoumise d'une demande de
scrutin public le scrutin est annoncé
dans l'ensemble de l'Assemblée nationale
la parole est à Monsieur Victor aberdeau
pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je t'aime et rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous apprêtons à voter
ce soir la proposition de loi visant à
davantage réguler le secteur de
l'influence et ses 15000 créateurs de
contenus et audience diverses après un
examen par l'Assemblée nationale et le
Sénat les députés et sénateurs ont
trouvé un accord jeudi dernier pour
mieux régler le marché des influenceurs
ce texte a pour objet de réguler un
secteur qui est jusqu'à présent
souffrait de zones grises au détriment
des consommateurs qui restaient parfois
de surcroît sans recours l'influence sur
les réseaux c'est en effet illustré ces
derniers temps par des abus et fait
l'objet de dénonciation et d'arnaque aux
conséquences potentiellement graves
l'objectif est donc de mieux lutter
contre ces dérives et Arna constaté
comme les incitations à faire des
régimes alimentaires dangereux de la
chirurgie esthétique des paris excessifs
ou encore la promotion de contrefaçon le
23 janvier dernier la direction générale
de la concurrence de la consommation et
de la répression des fraude publiée
justement une étude accablante montrant
que 60% des influenceurs et des agences
contrôlées ne respectez pas la
réglementation sur la publicité et le
droit des consommateurs cette
proposition de loi est ainsi une
première étape elle crée renforce un
appareil juridique qui est
responsabilisera et le cas échéant
sanctionnera tous les influenceurs mais
aussi leurs agences les annonceurs et
les plateformes de diffusion les
républicains se félicitent que l'on ait
réussi à définir de la façon la plus
précise possible l'activité
d'influenceurs nous sommes ravis que
plusieurs de nos propositions ont été
retenues et que la rédaction finale
issue du Sénat nous satisfait pleinement
j'en profite ici d'ailleurs pour saluer
ici le travail transpartisan et
intelligent que nous avons su faire mais
aussi en particulier celui de ma
collègue Virginie du bimmüller qui a été
très engagée sur ce texte ces mesures
sur le point d'être définitivement voté
ce soir à l'Assemblée nationale vont
enfin permettre un encadrement un peu
plus abouti du monde des influenceurs et
de leur activité avec davantage de
transparence dans les messages
promotionnels et dans les activités
publicitaires avec cette proposition de
loi la représentation nationale envoie
quoi qu'il en soit un message fort à
notre jeunesse et qui peut être fasciné
parfois par cet argent qui semble si
facilement gagner par les influenceurs
et dont ceux-ci font parfois être à
l'âge alors que d'autres après 10 années
d'études ne voient pas encore la couleur
d'un premier salaire le groupe les
républicains soutiendra donc évidemment
ce texte comme il en a soutenu le
principe depuis le début il est urgent
de donner un cadre de référence au
métier d'influenceurs afin de protéger
les consommateurs en particulier les
plus jeunes et les plus vulnérables nous
voterons donc en faveur de cette
proposition de loi qui comprend des
avancées nécessaires pour enfin réguler
cette activité en actant un strict cadre
légal à l'activité d'influenceurs qui
ces dernièrement développé de façon
exponentielle nous érons désormais de la
part du gouvernement que les moyens pour
cette mise en application suivront
également
merci monsieur le député
la discussion générale est close
nous en venons au texte de la commission
mixte paritaire conformément à l'article
113 alinéa 3 du règlement je vais
appeler l'assemblée à statuette d'abord
sur l'amendement dont je suis saisie
amendement au texte de la CMP un moment
numéro 1 présenté par madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente très
rapidement cet amendement vient juste
compléter l'article 2 B pour inclure
l'autorité nationale des jeux lanj au
sein du processus d'élaboration par
l'Autorité de régulation de la
communication audiovisuelle est
numérique du référentiel que devront
respecter les mécanismes mis en place
par les plateformes dans le but
d'exclure les publics mineurs des
publicités relatives au jeu d'argent et
de hasard rien de plus je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis merci madame la
Présidente ce sera évidemment un avis
favorable qui vient rectifier un oubli
de lors de cette commission mixte
paritaire qui avait lors de
l'élaboration du principe d'exclusion
des mineurs pour la publicité des jeux
et de Hajar et je réponds ainsi à ma
collègue du groupe communiste qui
considérait que les mineurs n'étaient
pas assez protégés ils ne pourront plus
demain voir de la publicité pour des
jeux d'argent et de hasard et si les
plateformes n'offrent pas de mécanisme
pour exclure les mineurs d'une
publication alors les plateformes ne
pourront plus diffuser ce type de
contenu c'est une avancée majeure qui
est le fruit d'un consensus
transpartisans l'ensemble du texte et
donc la NJ pourra donner son avis sur
l'élaboration de ce référentiel pour une
belle avancée contenue dans cette loi
je mets donc au voie cet amendement qui
a reçu un double avis favorable
commission et gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté nous allons
maintenant procéder au scrutin je vais
mettre au voile à proposition de loi je
vous prie de bien vouloir regagner vos
places le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin éclos
voici le résultat du scrutin
votant 194 exprimés 194 majorité 98 pour
194 contre 0 l'Assemblée nationale à
adopter
c'est la même manière
monsieur le rapporteur
5 secondes madame la Présidente pour
juste remercier l'ensemble des collègues
pour cette uneanimité qui confirme
finalement l'intérêt pour ce texte pour
conclure empruntons une phrase à un
gredin ici on fait la loi pas la police
la justice mais c'est une belle loi
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous merci pour ce sixième vote
unanime merci à nos collaborateurs
Léopold egotier merci aux
administrateurs qui nous ont accompagnés
que ce soit à Bercy ou l'Assemblée
nationale merci Benjamin
bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]